so uh let's go let's check out this top
anime series list um already already I
I'm about to throw hands can I say that
I this is my least favorite Trend in the
anime Community when they when people
like a show a lot a new show is airing
they're like let's get it to the top of
my anime list it's all let's all go and
write 10 Stars uh and all it does is
invite people to be like you guys are
[__] idiots yeah no I feel like
here's here's the marketing strp right
you uh you you make a new anime how do
you get hype you make a bunch of bots
because at the time of this recording uh
so freen has not finished airing we're
about 12
episodes about halfway through at the
time of this recording so how the [__]
could it be a 9 and so here here's the
threat you release a new anime make some
Bots upvote your favorite anime it gets
above full meta Alchemist Brotherhood
people start talking about it free
marketing it's the infinite hype glitch
I mean that's where we are now so sad
that that's the only way you can get
people to start [__] watching your
show nowadays so do you I mean you're I
think you're the only one of us who's
currently watched this show yes I've
watched the show and I've read the Manga
as
well I've also read the Manga as well
yeah this is a great show and uh it is a
very very very good show I enjoying it a
lot likewise yeah uh I don't think it's
the best show no of uh all time no I
don't even think it's the best show of
the year I would argue might not even be
the best show of the season I think it's
an incredibly solid show but I wouldn't
even put it in the top 50 if I'm being
what would what would beat it this
season do you think potentially probably
probably SK 2 um which let's be real
we're going to see eventually on this
list we're going to see if free Ren is
number one we're going to see it on this
list but I mean I [__] love free run
I I don't want to I don't want to like
make it seem like I'm [__] on free
you're just saying that this is this is
overblown this is this is clearly
recency by because here's the thing that
I don't uh I don't understand where
people see like one or two episodes and
then I remember when oshoko as well I
don't know if this is going to be theist
uh where one episode release and
everyone was just like greatest anime of
all time 10 out 10 Masterpiece they said
that about like chainsaw man as well
they said that about like a lot of the
big [__] hype as [__] shows right I
feel like it's a right of passage for a
show to get fully hype to beat full met
Alchemist Brotherhood as the top rated
show in Ma and every every hype new show
needs to go through that right of
passage
yeah but like fale Alchemist is the
final boss yeah it really is like The
Undefeated boss unfortunately you have
to be afraid of the old man in the in
the job surrounded by new kids cuz uh he
he probably knows what's up I I always
like to say that the for arham's
Brotherhood is like the ocar of time
equivalent to anime you know where it's
like it's there had like obviously
people love it a lot of people claim it
as a masterpiece like a 10 out of 10
show and they'll always be like that one
new show that just you know people are
talking about more people trying to like
yeah gets challenged as like the king
but at the end of the day people are
still going to come to that agreement in
the long run of no but that's still the
goat yeah like I think free rent is a
very very good show it has one of the
best kind of like here's the biggest
thing that surprised me about freerun
which is you know it's kind of like it
marketed itself as like a very emotional
gripping show and then it has these
Banger action scenes that just come out
of nowhere what it reminded me was do
you remember when you watch Like A Slice
of Life K Animation Show like made
Dragon or something then out of nowhere
there would just be this like [__]
Banger action scene that nobody asked
for but nobody's going to complain about
but they did not have to go that hard
that is free like Toro and Ka figh I was
like this does not include this doesn't
feel right in the show but I'm here for
it outside of J kaon uh this has some of
the best action scenes I've seen all
year and it's a uh and it's a [__]
fantasy show beautifully written story
beautiful show this is the top 50 list
if you ballpark you making a top 50
would fre be in the top 50 no as I said
earlier I absolutely love the show I
love the manga I think it's a very
refreshing show especially in this day
and age but I I I just I don't think I'd
even put in the top 50 top 100 maybe but
not in the top 50 I I would have
possibly top 50 I it's too early to tell
right now I yeah I mean it's it's not
even [__] finished I hate this why do
they do this I think caught up with
manga so I'm a lot further ahead in the
story so I know what's to come in the
anime but and I I love the direction
that the manga is going in right now but
like I just I don't know I feel like
this is going to be one of those like
solid shows that you'll remember for a
long time but when you think of like the
Pinnacle of anime how can you call this
the goat of anime when it's not even
done right yeah my my biggest concern
with freen right now is I'm afraid that
the plot is going to drag I feel like it
has such a good idea as an opening it's
opening like kind of scenes and opening
ideas are so [__] good and they made
me cry I'm wondering how long it can
carry on with the idea of just like this
being like a Immortal elf and seeing the
eyes of like the world through this
Immortal elf I'm seeing I I I'm going to
give it the benefit of the doubt and see
and hope that it can continue being as
good as it has been fantastic show
please watch it but it's not number one
not number one but right of passage you
know let's talk about the real goats
happy cuz for the once in our life I can
talk about anime that g
hasn't this is this is okay then
question to you uh since for metal
arham's Brotherhood has been just like
the the longstanding king of the Min
list list do you think it deserves to be
the number one
spot I'm going to pull a trash taste uh
and I'm going to talk about show I
haven't seen and just uh completely uh
just you know what's [__] up is that
you're so good about talking about anime
you can probably say more about the show
than I can I've watched I've watched the
thing okay can I can I see my opinion
sure all right so like it has some of
like for its time it has some of the
like best animation for like some of the
fight scenes uh like that fight where
Hughes does like the [__] is it
Hughes that's his name right okay I'm
I'm just going to Contin talk that guy
where to see where you the fire guy do
oh yeah Rob yeah no oh yeah Hughes is
like the dad yeah right that's Hughes is
the dad so like that was that was like
he's such a cool character when did when
did you think it became [__] cuz if
you're if you're a trash
tast randomly say [__] I mean like I
don't think he was [__] I just think he
was like overrated right okay so like
the do mean the Edward Brothers um like
you know they had some really really
good writing did you call them the
Edward Brothers is that not it's the El
Brothers Edward is one
character you know Edward Edward and
alons
Edward Mario it's like Mario Mario Mario
Luigi Mario yeah it's Edward Edward
that's that's the brother the Mario
Brothers which is what they are called
the Mario Brothers right yeah it's Mario
Mario and Luigi Mario so [__] up yeah
yeah anyway the Edward Brothers Brothers
um you know I think it started to fall
off where you know with the dog scene uh
the the dog scene Nina yeah Nina Nino
whatever her name is the dog scene that
was just that that was like they were
trying too hard of course it was going
to be sad of of course the dog was going
to be sad guys of God I feel like I feel
like I'm reading r/ anime right now but
it did have some Banger fights uh Roy
Mustang popped off absolutely when he
did the fire thing uh against one of and
then when he cries in the rain and he's
like it's a bad day for rain oh that
that that too that was that was oh s you
know as as it kind of feels like it's
like just saying like when you do a top
food list of all time you're like pizza
number one you're like yeah yeah I mean
I guess that I mean like that's like no
one's going to say no but you kind of
feel like you wish you had a more
exciting answer for number one you know
I mean full male Alchemist is it feels
like such a complete experience uh in
every way and it feels like it Nails
everything it wants to do I think what
definitely helped as well with
Brotherhood to push it into that status
of like I guess the the pizza equivalent
of anime where like everybody likes it
and you can't really complain that it's
your favorite is the fact that it came
right after like the original Full Medal
which had a bunch of problems which I
watched that one first yeah right and so
did I right and so like because you kind
of had the not to say that the original
for metal anime is bad or anything but
they definitely fixed a lot of the
issues the original had in Brotherhood
and I think that whole like fixing the
issues type of thing to make it more of
a perfect package I think kind of
shifted the way that people view
Brotherhood in like as as a series by
itself but like I don't know maybe this
is just me but like to me Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood is in a bit of a
biased spot because this for a lot of
people was the first introduction to
anime right like I think when a lot of
people think of like formale Alchemist
Brotherhood or they think of like
starting to get into it does pay to be
one of the first animes you watch you
look at it with and obviously you know a
lot of people are recommending it
because they think it's a great show and
I think it's also great a safe
recommendation is it's a safe
recommendation here's the thing though
okay let's say let's say frean didn't
exist in this month or whatever and for
met Alchemist is still on top can you
name a show that deserves to be not not
necessarily one that you like more but
can you say can you put a show above
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood that
deserves that number one spot that's the
hard thing is you can't I can't
personally think of a show yeah that I I
think deserves to be high yeah if you
take away all personal bias towards this
show it really is the perfect show that
anybody can watch right and you you
could have watched 100 shows a, shows
zero shows and you will most likely come
out of Brotherhood being like that was a
really good show because it is a really
good show uh I personally wouldn't put
it as number one okay but I think in
terms of the overall anime viewing
experience for every type of anime fan
out there it is the safest pick and I
and that's why I understand why it's the
number one position okay question number
two do you think that for met Alchemist
Brotherhood would be as let's
say as beloved
came out now if it came out now because
I think I think and this is me talking
out complete speculation having not seen
Brotherhood um I think that for
Alchemist Brotherhood came out at a
perfect time where we didn't have this
whole not not exactly toxicity but the
whole kind of like mid era of anime
where you know what I'm talking about
where where this is everyone has pure
nice Nostalgia when they look at for met
Alchemist Brotherhood cuz no one was
really it came out at a time where anime
fans weren't really as competing with
each other as much as like they are now
yeah they were just happy to watch any
show at that point I think it also came
out at a time when the internet was
really allowing uh kind of to watch
anime a lot easier uh and I think
obviously people were looking for like
the newest and greatest show and I think
it came out at a time that was literally
perfect it came out in the in the anime
era where everyone was just happy to
meet anyone who liked anime yeah uh it
it took advantage to the internet it it
it in English as well had a fantastic
dub which immediately helped it uh it
with Western fans cuz back then you know
a lot of people watch dubs yeah and I
think it's it's kind of in the same way
for Arkham's Brotherhood I think is a
lot similar to Cowboy Bop in that sense
where like the general I guess niceties
and like uh you know a claim that it got
was mostly from Weston fans right like
obviously you know Full Metal Alchemist
was huge in Japan when he came out as
well obviously but for Alchemist is not
talked about as fondly amongst Japanese
fans as it is with Western fans that's
true yeah I've never every time I talk
about people with anime it never comes
out yeah when you mention foral
Alchemist they're just like oh I haven't
heard that in a while you know it's it's
kind of one of those shows where people
look fondly back at it but they don't
it's not in the constant you know
Zeitgeist of talking about shows that
were huge at the time it was just
another at the end of the day I think to
a lot of Japanese anime fans who are
around wind for medal was around it was
just another really solid sh in show
yeah because I personally think that
fullment Alchemist for the Western
Community which is what my anim my anime
list is it came out at the perfect time
and it was the complete package which
was very rare for anime at the time um
and it's now looked back with you know
back in the day the only its biggest
competition was probably something like
the big three and the big three were
just fighting against each other on who
was most popular around the big three
where we had and then on like the side
kind of like place we had full metal
Alchemists coming up being like hey this
is another Shonen that is a complete
package unlike these other big long
running shownin and it's very well well
written and it's finished and people
will look back at that fondly yeah it
also helps that it was only 64 episodes
where if you compare it to the big three
it was obviously for new anime Watchers
it was a lot harder to get into Naruto
or bleach or one piece of the time
whereas for metal if you tried you could
finish it in a few days you know because
I you know when it comes to the question
of can I think of an anime that deserves
to go above F Metal Alchemist and I'm
saying this having not like watched it
but only come only knowing about its
Legacy and thinking about if full meta
Alchemist Brotherhood came out today I
think full met Alchemist Brotherhood if
it came out today it would have a
similar reception to something like
Attack on Titan to me Attack on Titan is
the modern day equivalent of an anime
package that is now it is a it is a
complete package and uh you know now now
there is a lot more anime coming out
there's a lot more competition to me as
like an anime viewer I think Attack on
Titan is one of the greatest modern
anime to come out yeah and I think I
think the only reason why Attack on
Titan is not above full m Alchemist
Brotherhood in this list is because it
came out you know incrementally in
multiple Seasons I kind of hate that
this list doesn't like to rate the whole
series yeah if cuz if Attack on Titan
was put under just Attack on Titan like
one name on this list I think it would
be above full metal I don't think so it
would be very close because there are
more there are more haters of Attack on
Titan it's yeah it's not about like how
you have but I think that's because it
came out at a time where anime fans have
become so much more critical so much
more nitpicky with their shows I think
if Attack on Titan had had all wrapped
up in 2012 it' probably be up I think
it'd be up it'd be ahead of but also
again yeah and I think as well like
because like you know with attack on tit
it did take such a long time and during
that time the anime Community really
shifted to being more nitpicky you know
where manga readers would be very
critical of the anime adaptations and
just getting very you know looking at
the fin of details way too much I feel
the only reason why people don't do that
with Brotherhood because at the end of
the day Brotherhood is not a perfect
show like there are problems with it I
think in no one ever talks about it
though but that's the thing and but
that's the thing people don't want to
talk about it because it's nostalgic to
so CU I've never heard someone called
for Mr of Alchemist Brotherhood mid you
know I I've just like I mean it's not
it's a great
it's not perfect but like I I think I
think the biggest like thing between
let's say fortive Alchemist and Attack
on Titan is for like for met Alchemist
anime was never never reached the
heights of popularity during that era as
the attack on Titan era you know and
Attack on Titan number one had way more
competition for high profile anime to go
up against so you have this kind of like
competitiveness between a big
high-profile show that's released
nowadays versus a big high-profile show
that back in the day and I think for
that reason I don't think in the western
anime Community we will ever get another
show that will be looked at uh with as
critical claim this is pro of concept
right that this is a 13 14y old show and
it's still highly regarded as one of the
greatest shows I've ever SE they don't
have a skin in fortnite so uh and TI
does so yeah yeah who's the real winner
yeah Wake Me Up When alons is
[__]